ron desantis governor of florida
suggests providing internet access to
the people of cuba
yesterday on july 14th desantis penned a
letter to joe biden
urging the biden administration to
provide internet access to the people of
cuba
who are protesting against their
communist government here is his tweet i
urge president biden to assist him
providing internet access to the people
of cuba standing up against communist
oppression and demanding a voice after
decades of suffering
under a cold dictatorship which is
really interesting because on july 11
i was sitting at home thinking you know
people in
cuba do not have broadband access in a
major way
and they're obviously got their own type
of firewall there and it's censored
i wonder and i'd say here in my tweet
just three days earlier and i don't know
if he saw my tweet or just
synchronicity a lot of people will come
to the same conclusion at the same time
given the same set of facts it's
probably that
more than anything cuba experts i
understand internet access
is censored and expensive in the country
idea would the u.s
beaming free internet into the country
be disruptive supportive of the people
i think it's certainly a possibility
from air water with various technologies
just thought obviously star link exists
obviously we've had loon and other you
know balloons and
low aircrafts could beam in and you
could beam directly
uh certain technologies so as of right
now desantis is plus 400 to win the 2024
republican primary closely trailing
trump who's plus 300
uh which is really interesting uh when
you think about it
nikki haley also and mike pence are
listed in the odds but that seems like a
long
shot so some quotes from the letter
technology exists to provide internet
access into cuba remotely using the
innovation of american enterprise and
the diverse industries
here but it doesn't explain the specific
technologies i wonder which one would
actually work the best because
some of the beaming technology would
require you to have a special type of
antenna on the other side
like wimax and those kind of
technologies i believe which people are
not going to have
in their computers or on their phones
but wi-fi is
so what you actually need to do is
figure out a way to get wi-fi into the
country which has a certain distance
and here is the quote similar to
american efforts to broadcast radio into
the soviet union during the cold war in
europe
the federal government has a history of
supporting the dissemination of
information into cuba
for the cuban people through radio and
television
through radio and television marti
located in miami
in addition to sending information
however our efforts must include
creating a means
for the cuban people to speak to the
world i i think we do need and somebody
here can fact-check me what would
email me dm me on twitter i'm at jason
or jason calacanis.com
tell me what would be the best way to do
this is it you know
um low airplanes beaming
wi-fi and how low would they have to be
in terms of the balloons that loon used
or aircrafts or could it be done with
boats and i don't know how close we can
get to the shores there
obviously if you could get starlink
satellites into the country they could
they could receive it that way but then
that would require somebody to have
hardware and become
the wi-fi router there which means that
person if they got caught
would be in big trouble uh obviously so
it's a really interesting uh concept but
i don't know
what technology actually does this
antonio garcia
martinez said now there's an interesting
idea so i think morally and politically
great idea
um i don't know the politics of cuba uh
and i'm not a super
expert on this but i do think um
we should be embracing uh
you know democracy anywhere there is
communism
and supporting the people in their fight
for freedom and if the internet can help
that
boy is that going to be transformative
and i think the entire space race that
we're seeing right now from spacex to
virgin galactic
and every other company blue origin
getting to space
so many great reasons to do it but
giving internet
low-cost broadband internet to the two
or three billion people who don't have
access to broadband today
and to the billion or two billion that
live in very rural areas
this is going to be a game changer uh
and
it's it's really the whole space where
ace is worth it just for that one
potentiality okay another story came up
today friend of the pod taylor lorenz
who was on
reported that facebook plans to pay
creators one billion dollars to use its
products
uh really interesting facebook for
decades
has been very greedy shared no money
with any of the creators
and now what's happened is it's not just
youtube giving money to
creators and influencers uh you have
other platforms like snapchat you're
spending a million dollars per day for
the past
five months to encourage creators to
create on it tick tock launched a 200
million dollar creator fund
and youtube recently announced it would
pay a hundred million dollars to
creators to use youtube shorts
it's tick tock competitor so creators
are getting paid on youtube tick tock
snapchat the only hold out has been the
very greedy
selfish non-sharing uh facebook
and now they're changing that i think
facebook realizes that creators are
looking to make money and they're going
to move to the platforms that pay them
the
most so with facebook making 25 billion
a quarter 100 billion a year
giving one percent to creators no big
deal if you look at youtube they give 55
of the advertising revenue on a video
two creators
now that's not 100 it's not 55 of all of
youtube's revenue because some of that
is on other videos
that maybe aren't sharing revenue but it
is a ton
of money is being spent by the other
platform so facebook
is dipping their toes smart move i think
it's going to work for them
people are on instagram and they want to
monetize
their uh celebrity and i think you know
this is
why people have left instagram to go to
only fans or instagram to
focus on youtube or leaving facebook and
instagram to focus on snapchat
or sub stack or patreon
and now you have twitter embracing this
with their
newsletter and super likes and
subscriptions
so um this is great for content creators
and
facebook is late to the party which is
not always the case for them
interestingly they're late to the party
in sharing money
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business
blog or publish content promote your
business announce upcoming events or
special projects
and sell products and services of all
kinds and more
they also have powerful ecommerce
functionality and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box so no matter what you're
using an ipad
a surface a iphone an android phone it
doesn't matter
all these beautiful templates just work
and of course it's got built-in seo free
and secure hosting
and 24 7 award-winning customer support
uh we we did remote demo day in 2020 we
were suffering through the pandemic we
were confused how are these startups
going to get funded i said you know what
throw up a squarespace site it's a
project
maybe it turns into a business and boy
did it ever we have now
funded over a dozen companies over 14
million dollars in funding
and this all from setting up a simple
squarespace website and tweeting it so
go to squarespace.com
twist for a free trial squarespace.com
slash twist for a free trial when you're
ready to launch
use the offer code twist and save ten
percent off your first purchase of a
website or domain and congratulations
for the team
uh going public by direct listing on
paid 19th what an amazing journey it's
been congratulations again
okay let's get back to this amazing
episode
you